hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the darkest word now I
was actually I'm in the game because I
was wandering around a bit and I
accidentally found a key and I found
this note so I'm just gonna go ahead and
jump right into it hey thanks again for
doing the supply run it's hard to find
willing men these days times are tough
in this new world anyway we need a new
spark plug most importantly so it'll do
you best to check out the mansion it
might actually have a brand new car if
we're lucky
who knows that's why we're sending you
on the job good luck John note to self
fuel is low so I might have no choice
but to find a brand new car oh I hope I
make it back oh I hope you don't sorry
it's just the truth I hope you don't go
anyway like I said I found the key over
there
or not wait a minute
give me Oh
e duh why didn't I do e sorry I've been
playing a few games where I have to
click to use stuff that is a dead body
warning to all survivors there has been
an unknown presence in the air that is
revered as a seer fears right turn back
now R okay um yeah keep yourself armed
with a Glock didn't save me I'm gonna
take excuse me
no can you thank you I'm gonna take your
gun anyway mister dead guy and go on my
merry way so thank you very much for an
O it's a Skellington excuse me
pause it nothing over here I believe it
will oh ok god damn it that's quite
annoying I believe that this is made on
the same engine can't go in there that
the old Slenderman shadow maps were made
on if you remember way back when like a
game maker or FPS creator oh excuse me
did you just trip and fall and die well
that was startling I hope the other
scares are better than that
hmmm what could possibly be up in this
dark place I don't even have a
flashlight so I guess I'm kind of doomed
to darkness
okay dolefully quiet what does that mean
hello key
nothing all right holiday mr. OHS
happening good Kali excuse me uh sorry
over lose the mic a lot ah how's the
youth all right then I knew something
was gonna happen I knew it was gonna
happen
I knew anyway least there's a legitimate
reason now a gun don't know where that
guy came from anyway
mrow real Oh actually I think this is
actually um similar engine to that game
that I just played recently dead lab
maybe maybe not
maybe I'm mistaken but anyway I got a
key so let's keep going
oh I just glide ever so gently done this
yeah get it here nope okay no I don't
know what that clanking sound is I just
be like an error with the footsteps or
something mm how about here
no no what the hell was it a specific
type of key was it like a something else
key what the hell I didn't see anything
else I like how it takes like one foot
stride I didn't take anything
Oh up here okay I didn't even eat here
Oh boys excuse me
okay oh crap I thought that was just
like a pop-up in a distance I didn't
expect it to come at me oh that's not
bad
it's not bad at all well done you got me
good job you know likey
hello but if you something else gonna
pop out of me
maybe in the blood stain on the floor oh
god damn I've got the volume turned way
up through every little noise like
jumping I don't know
whoa get up
well nourishes does mr air oh this looks
good what is this a bathroom
get up bathroom is this it's a medieval
dungeon in here what is it what is it I
don't want to know you know what I don't
want to know why did I want it okay get
your bear I didn't want to know in the
first place why did I want to know now I
got a key I guess there's another locked
door somewhere hmm Oh nurse no no no no
you shot up nurse I don't want anything
to do with you
ooh shoot me turn it on random lights oh
stop that with those lights on before or
am I just being fooled
what's going on here I have to admit
when I first started playing I wasn't I
didn't have that high expectations oh
this is interesting
hey Brianna there we go what is that
what is that who's that huh what
happened what happened who's that was
out of the thing god damn it huh he
didn't even do anything you didn't even
yell at me could God ha
nope no no no no no no no no I don't
know what the hell I just found but I
never ever ever ever ever ever ever want
to see it again that was more disturbing
than the monster out here use me I are
still there oh you're so slow and creepy
now oh oh what's wrong with your face
I don't have anymore ah
tell her to fine you're just trying to
get up hi oh hi
you're quick quick yeah I don't know
what I did
I flipped a swatch oh I didn't close the
door on him
Oh what did I do you always see what I
did
I have AMRO I could close that door on
you
we'll just blows it okay never mind he's
okay I don't think he'll catch up to me
oh oh excuse me oh that's a statue where
am I now
thank you please die good job
wait what
did I do that Wow huh okay I guess what
the hell okay that was the weirdest mix
of what the [ __ ] and terrifying
I've ever experienced that was something
I gotta admit that was a whole lot of
something what
oh no he's huh anyway that's pretty good
I guess I guess oh alright it startled
me and made me weirded out so anyway it
went well I liked it it was pretty good
though thank you all so much for
watching click the enter days for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
the waters may attack this dark
I can hold the axe friend
occupy me it work for me an ex
I'm sure it can work
I am missing
I feel I feel the stupid come on Bobby
through the spine so if you guys are
like see something but remember I
haven't played this game if I have no
idea what I'm do